viewed from a rooftop
filmed by a terrified witness an attack
that traumatized and changed a nation
after the murders at the headquarters of
magazine charlie hebdo
france became a different more nervous
country facing
fundamental questions about free speech
and religion
a verdict has been reached but the
effects linger to this day
this is still a quiet street but now it
carries
memories of the victims of a bleak and
brutal morning
[Music]
january 2015 two heavily armed men
attacked the offices of charlie hebdo
many of the staff had received death
threats for years
after publishing caricatures of the
prophet muhammad
within minutes 12 people are dead
including eight journalists
and two police officers
the man shouts out the prophet muhammad
has been avenged
we have killed charlie hebdo and then
the pair drive off
this man was the first doctor on the
scene he'd written for charlie hebdo
among the victims were some of his close
friends
the attack that took place inside this
building shocked france not just because
of its
callous brutality but also because
charlie hebdo was only targeted because
the magazine
had chosen to publish some cartoons that
some people
found deeply offensive and the
repercussions of this attack
and those cartoons continue to be felt
the faces of the charlie hebdo
cartoonists look out from this mural
among them george wallinsky who was 80
years old when he was shot
we went to talk to his widow even now
long after her husband's murder
she lives with 24-hour police protection
[Music]
she says that despite the pain it's
caused charlie hebdo
was right to publish the caricatures
[Music]
of
these were the killers brothers syed and
sheriff kawachi
themselves killed by police a couple of
days later after a manhunt that finished
on the outskirts of paris
as that unfolded another attack was
launched on a jewish
supermarket in the east of the capital
by a close friend of the kochie brothers
ahmedi kulabali who had also pledged
allegiance to the islamic state
took several hostages and killed four
people
the siege was ended when heavily armed
police stormed the building
shooting and killing coulee valley
this series of attacks prompted a year
of heightened alert across france
and the worst fears were realized in
november 2015
when 130 people were killed in one
terrible evening in paris at the
bataclan concert hall
and in nearby bars it was the worst
attack in france
since the second world war the country
entered a state of emergency
more than five years on and finally in
this paris courtroom
a trial of those suspected of being
accomplices
to the grim attacks in january 2015
men and women accused of helping the
three attackers plan
and execute the murders of so many
people
at the start of the trial charlie hebdo
made the controversial
provocative decision to republish those
caricatures
a move that once again brought a return
to violent attacks
returning france to its highest level of
terror alert
an echo of what happened in 2015.
the karachi brothers came up the stairs
in this building that went through
these double doors and into the offices
of charlie hebdo
where they carried out the attack that
seemed to change
france but that wasn't the end of the
story for this building
five years later it was targeted once
again
two people from this office were stabbed
as they smoked a cigarette outside
once again the police swarmed the area
both victims survived but with
serious long-term injuries the attacker
thought they were workers from charlie
hebdo in fact the magazine had moved
years before not long after came the
beheading
of teacher samuel patty in the paris
suburbs and then
a triple murder inside the basilica in
nice
both have been linked to anger caused by
the caricatures
the french government though unwavering
in its support of
free speech and the legal right to
[Music]
blaspheme
his words were derided as posturing by
some majority muslim countries
in bangladesh this huge anti-french
protest
turkey's president accused president
macron of being
mentally unfit france is home to six
million muslims
more than any other european nation and
the tension is
clear this paris mosque was closed due
to alleged links with radicalization
but worshipers here and across the
capital have insisted they reject
violence
among the many muslim clerics to condemn
the attack was kemadu gassama
an imam at one of the city's mosques
france remains a nervous country where
people cherish freedom of expression
and talk of terrorism as if it's a war
without end
time has passed but the nerves remain
the scars of charlie hebdo haven't
healed
adam parsons sky news paris